you know they smoke rubbers in these
little dodge
chargers the challenger cars so i kind
of leaned out i could
i don't want you to lose control of your
car he was a skinhead dude too but he
was cool
he like all right cool no problem two
dudes on the pickup said
mind you been this [ __ ] now once again
watch this back to the meek mill
situation
it's five six seven in the parking lot i
could have said
it was six of them and i was wanting me
so i left
nah the politics i come from they just
so happened to catch me on the day that
i'm by myself
i gotta get down this is what this is
i could have pulled out in the world
wouldn't have never known those white
dudes ain't on social media they
probably know who i was
right but the politics embedded in me
i got to get down however it turned out
i don't know they got knives on them
guns i don't know what they got on them
i didn't realize it was three four more
over there in the corner as you seen
them walk up mm-hmm you know what i'm
saying so it was kind of and even with
that i was one of them on the defense
thing i couldn't really
attack like i wanted to because i saw
them walking up so i had to get back to
the vehicle
you know in case [ __ ] went somewhere
else right so um
that's just what it is bro and you know
i
first want to tell you kids don't gang
bang
right it's some irrational [ __ ] that it
won't get you nowhere
there's no retirement plan you know what
i mean uh your homeboy is gonna hate
on you when you go to jail they're gonna
tell your girlfriend about your other
broad
and they're gonna be at her too and
that's something i'm gonna tell on you
and all that
right uh be a civilian be able to live
life the worldly way be able to say you
know what let me pull off
you know what let me go make a report
that's the peaceful way because this
[ __ ] that we under
is irrational is unreasonable and it's
dangerous
and i don't wish it on nobody